♪ ♪ ♪LaLaLaLa DPJ venait souvenz
nous. Tout ce qu'ils voyaient
c'était pas correct, tout ce que
c'était juste négatif.
- Ça c'est à moi!
Aller jouer avec des casseroles
c'est négligent, aller jouer
tout seul dans mon jardin
- Ces jeunes parents se sont
Aller jouer avec des casseroles
c'est négligent, aller jouer
tout seul daesesesesesesesesese.
- Ces jeunes parents se sont
Ils ont rapidement un premier
bébé. À ce moment-là, ils vivent
en ville, loin de leurs famille.
- On s'était chicané puis la
voisine d'ene e e e e e e e e e,
puis on a eu un signalement.
- Leur dossier s'aggrave quand
la DPJ juge que le bébé a un
de négligence, mais on saura
plus tard qu'il a un trouble
du spectre de l'au
- Tout a coup ils disaient:
"votre enfant ne par
- C'est parce qu'il venait juste
d'avoir un an e e e e temps-la
- Il comprenait mon enfant,
mais il ne parlait pas encore.
J'étais choquée quand
ils avaient dit ça.
- Le couple a quatre enfants
en moins de six ans. Deux ont
Les parents sont dépassés,
la DPJ retire mimimimimimimimim.
- Chaque fois qu'ils venaient
à l'improviste, je me sentais
toujours pas bien à l'intérieur
de moije me sentais rabaissé.
On dirait que nous autresetetets
de moi. sesesesentais intimidé,
je me sentais rabaissé.
On dirait que nous autres
et qu'eux autres sont toujours
trrrrrès grands.
- Les enfants sont d'abord
envoyés chez leurs grands-DPDPDJ
décide de les placer plutôt dans
d'expérience avec les autistes.
droit de les voir, une fois par
mois pendant quelqueeseseses.
- On a perdu beaucoup à cause
d'eux autres aussi.
- Qu'est-ce que vous avez perdu?
- Bien... cococococococococococl
des fois, parce que c'est moi
qui emmenait mes petits-enfants
à leur famille d'accueil.
C'était comme ça à chaque mois,
je sais pas.. c'était comme
aller les abandonner.
- Pendant cette période,
le papa commence à boire après
ses journées de travail.
- J'avais beaucoup de pression
a a a a vie; j'avais ma job,
j'avais ma petite famille avec
toutes les demandes de la DPJ.
À untntntnt donné j'ai été
violent, ça a beaucoup aggraver
le dossier. Il y a eu la DPJ
a eu raison dans certains
points.
- dededede suivre une thérapie,s
il ne réussit pas à sortir
du cycle infernal. jusqu'àrererr
au nouveau système
d'intervention d'autorité
atikamekw.
CONSTANT AWASHISH, gNaNaNaNaNaNw
- On va pouvoir s'occuper de nos
enfantleur intégrité.
- En 2018, les Atikamekws sont
les premiers autocht o o o o o e
gérer la protection de l'enfance
sur leur territoire.
Leur but : garder les enfants
que possible.COCOCOCOLE BLACK, e
d'intervention atikamekw
- On ne veut pas déraciner.
le passé, il y a eu des enfants
qui ont été placés à lieieieieur
puis on les a pas revus.
- Nicole Black accompagne depuis
23 ans des enfants assssssssssss
difficiles.  Elle a travaillé
avec la DPJ, puis au sein
du Système d'intervention
d'autorité atikamekw, le SIAA.
- Ce que j'ai vu, moi, dans ma
pratique, c'est que la DPJ quanc
ses grands talons tandis que
le SIAA c'est... on s'en va
tranquillement, on n'impose pas,
on bouscule pas non plus.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Cet aue e e e e e e e e e e ee
de leurs petits-enfants.
Les lulululus vieux ont d'abord
vécu cinq ans dans une famille
d'accueil. Ils ne parlent plus
omomomomomomomomomomomomomomomos
et soeurs.♪♪♪♪ ♪ ♪
- Tu aimes ça être ici?
Qu'est-ce que tu aimes?
- J'aime ça quand kukum me donne
q q q qu'est-ce que tu aimes
ici?
- J'aime toute!
à préserver l'identité et
la culture des enfants qtttt
sous leur protection.
- Il y a les valeurs
traditionnelles qu'on enseigne
à nos enfants. Parce
les deenenenenenenenenenenenene,
ils ne comprenaient pas.
Puis là ils commencent à parler.
les parents pour qu'on vous
demande de vous occuper de vos
petits-enfants?
- Une fois on les avait visités
sans les prévenir et rendu
à leur domicileà La Tuque,
j'ai vu ma fille avec des
cigarettes, sur les bras.
Puis il y avait une morsure.
- À ce moment-lpapapapapapapapas
une famille d'accueil.
Quand l'autorité atikamekw
prend le dossier en charge,ararn
organise un conseil de famille.
Cette étape est au coeur de
- Quand on retire un enfant
de son milieu, on passe tout le
temps en premier vers la famille
élargie, le "mononcle",
la "matante", les grands-
- Comment ça se passe?
Les gens se fâchent, pleurent,
c'est serein?
- Oui, la colère, on le sent,il,
les rires.
- Une solution est trouvée.
- Si on ne s'entend paeieieiein
de la famille élargie,
la discussion se poursuit avec
parent continue de serererer
à une mesure, le dossier est
référé au tribunal.
la judiciarisation des dossiers
a chuté de 80 %.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Ce premier couple, dont
on vous a parlé au début, a eu
que la DPJ cherchait toujours
p p p prendre en faute. Selon
eux, l'autorité atananananananac
une approche ancrée dans leur
culture.e e e e e e e e e e e ee
de thérapie, c'était basée sur
la tradition. J'ai beaucoup
appris... j'ai bpppp
appris... la guérison culturelle
et tradi
- C'est quoi ces traditions-là
qui vous ont aidé?
forêt. C'est aller me
ressourcleleleler chercher
mes outils, aller me guérir.
- Le père, qui n'avait jamais
été violent avant l'intervention
de la DPJ, a appris à gérer
sa colère. Ce qui a permis
de réunir la famille.
Les quatre enfants vivent
maintenantleleleleurs parents.
Avec le soutien continu
du système d'int